now back in March of 2021 you all
remember this the doj announced that it
was investigating Florida Congressman
Matt Gates over whether he had a sexual
relationship with a 17 year old girl and
paid her to travel with him as a
violation of sex trafficking laws well
gates at the time and to this day says
none of it was true
now the media and even some of his
Congressional colleagues didn't care
they baselessly smeared him over one of
the most vile accusations imaginable
Matt Gates who is you know pretty close
at some point to hopefully being diver
being a pedophile it's an indictment of
today's GOP a party that elevates the
ignorant the racist the fabulous and the
fraud Matt Gates the credible charges of
sex trafficking Matt Gates is an alleged
child sex trafficker who has been under
Federal criminal investigation he
decided who would be the speaker
to get a sense of how truly awful those
people are some of those comments even
came after
investigators recommended against
charges last year
now today the final Vindication as the
doj officially decided it will not
pursue any charges joining me now is
Florida Gates Congressman I mean I know
you feel Vindicated but listening to
those comments from the people who
always rush out and say innocent until
proven guilty
that's got to make your blood boil
yeah I got the news today in sort of a
surreal fashion I was interviewing an
FBI whistleblower in a transcribed
interview when my lawyers got this
information from doj and remember
project Veritas got a CNN director on an
undercover video saying that the reason
the media was propagandizing my life and
telling these lies about me breathlessly
over and over is because I'm effective
at impacting legislation and like when
CNN criticizes me you have to think are
they projecting a little bit like wasn't
it the CNN president of the company that
had to step aside because of sexual
allegations wasn't it their top rated
show Cuomo that had to get canceled
because of lies and cover-ups over
sexual allegations and then it was their
own legal analyst who had no problem
opining as to the lies about me then has
to step aside because he was doing
unspeakable things on a zoom broadcast
so I don't really take my p's and q's
from the mainstream media for the last
two years I've been fighting for my
constituents and the mainstream media
largely has been like a refuge for
scoundrels and Weirdos
well Congressman Gates a lot of people
at the time
said when these charges were made
against you that this was you were they
were picking you off
you know they targeted Trump with
Russian collusion and then a whole
series of conservatives would be
similarly targeted smeared maligned
until they just gave up
what's your message tonight to effective
conservative communicators time to pay
attention what's going on well we we all
have to watch our back because that's
where the target is but I can tell you
that I drew great inspiration from the
way president Trump didn't let the
process become the punishment he forged
ahead to Institute policies regarding
our border regarding our economy and I
also look to the mentorship of my friend
Jim Jordan who also faced totally false
allegations and was in a position where
he continued to lead on critical
Republican efforts so I know folks don't
always agree with my perspective on
everything but I have been working to
impact the Congress in a positive way
get us out of Foreign Wars focus on the
border and now I serve on the committee
focused on the weaponization of this
government against our people and having
been through the experiences of my life
I hope I'm able to Be an Effective
member of that panel
Congressman we appreciate it thank you
very much